[Music]  the people's champion hey I was so  shocked and thrilled to make it yes as a  to the finale never mind  you know the finals yes this was amazing  and just the fact that I got to do every  dance possible it makes me happy you  know I mean because I didn't want it to  end you know so uh I'm I'm thrilled with  third place I got a medal you know what  I mean it's pretty good it wasn't like  you got the ribbon for participation oh  I got your dancing isn't gonna have to  stop because you're going on tour dude  did you think that you would be asked to  go on the Dancing with the Stars tour  when this all started  never but it's the only thing getting me  through tonight because they otherwise  that would be so miserably slap well no  like I think as I know I get to continue  for the next 14 weeks of dancing every  day I mean unfortunately for her she has  to put up with me but he'll be it'll be  fun I'm so excited yeah this journey  doesn't end here which is great  [Music]  you